a massive effort to normalize this you
see the New York Times column say well
the Trump people have a case you see the
head of JP Morgan Chase the largest bank
in the United States saying well they
they're right about some things there is
a chance that Trump could win this
election and the way that he wins if
he's treated as a normal
candidate of course if Trump was as
wacky as they say they would want him on
TV as often as possible right and then
there was this moment when v ramaswami
threw down with Charlamagne the god this
morning Trump will say something they
will pick one word he says and then
actually have you respond to it talk
about the actual substance about what we
need to address it's hard to when you
got a guy who says he wants to be a
dictator for a day you got it's hard
when it's a guy who says it's hard when
it's a guy who says you got to terminate
terminate the constitution in order to
overturn the results of an election it's
hard when it's a guy who done who L and
attempted Co this country the
derangement
syndrome former 2024 Republican
presidential candidate V ramaswami joins
us now I thoroughly enjoyed your
exchange he's kind of a fun guy I mean
he you know he he brings on people who
disagree with him so I respect
Charlemagne the God for doing that a lot
of leftwing people won't do that but
they still don't really get why millions
and millions of Americans like Trump do
they they don't understand it
I'd like to think I made some progress
we were supposed to go for 45 minutes we
went for an hour and a half and one of
the things I had him do Laura was he
said Trump is quoting Hitler and that he
couldn't get off of that so I said let's
pull up the exact quote of what Donald
Trump exactly said oh no because I know
Donald Trump and he's not a guy who
quotes Adolf Hitler turns out it was
just a basic statement of a border
crisis that we have and it happens to
coincide with things that a bunch of
other people have said through human
history and I think that did change
their mind a little bit because they
hadn't even known what Donald Trump
Trump's quote was they just know what
MSNBC says that it was and I think this
is our path to winning in November in a
landslide Laura stick to the truth cut
through those left-wing media narratives
and get to the actual facts free speech
is the American way let every people
hear the best argument from every
candidate and make the right choice at
The Ballot Box and that's exactly what
these people want to prevent from
happening but the more work committed
actually our side is committed to free
speech the more likely we are to deliver
a landslide and I think that's what's
coming this November okay just for fun I
want to play another clip from this uh
interview now you made a very a Salient
point I think about American sentiment
toward our founding fathers this was
great watch John Adams you know his son
is John quinsey Adams you know what he
went back to congress with was one thing
he regretted not doing as a president
was abolishing slavery but you can't
tell people just to ignore the fact that
Thomas Jefferson I'm not telling people
to ignore to say that we're not going to
listen to Thomas Jefferson or their
founding was illegitimate because they
were deeply imperfect and flaw
is every bit as bad as somebody who's
going to say that I'm going to entirely
dismiss the fact that they were slave
owners first of all vake nice looking in
the black T-shirt okay that was that was
very cool to be on with them for that
but um why do you think so why do you
think some Republicans seem to have such
difficulty with the American um past in
history they get they get very scared
when they're talking about people like
Thomas Jefferson see look I I'm open
about the fact that Thomas Jefferson was
my favorite President he signed the
Declaration of Independence Laura at the
age of 33 while also while also actually
inventing the swivel chair think about
that these people were inventors they
were intellectuals and yes they were
also our founding leaders were they
imperfect of course they were in the
same way that you and I and every
American and every person today is too
and the Very people who are decrying our
founding fathers for being the
slaveholders following the written line
you're supposed to recite Republicans
and Democrats alike they're the very
people who would have been the slave
holders 250 years ago and so our
founding fathers they were not the
conformists they were the Pioneers they
were the explorers and what I want to
revive is that founding Spirit not by
claiming that they were perfect but by
recognizing their imperfections they
were still committed to the pursuit of a
more perfect union and that's what we
are as a country we're not perfect but
we're founded on the pursuit of a more
perfect union that is what makes America
great and I think that's what
Republicans need to be stopped by being
so shy about and start actually
celebrating and wearing on Our Sleeve if
you ever get a chance to um debate or
talk to like kamla Harris and Biden's
not going to be debating I don't think
anyone but be good just to say why
shouldn't George Washington be banned if
you're going to take all these other
names off all these statues down why why
should Washington still be around as any
figure we rever given his slave holding
past I'll file that away Laura and I'm
looking forward to hearing cel's answer
I don't expect it to be super coherent
but I'll be sure to Face Off With Her On
It All right but she'll repeat the same
phrase over and over again all right B
great to see you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else